so there are ammo types in this you are
we gonna do separate intros I'm guessing
to talk about whatever we need to talk
about on here yeah I was gonna do that
in post use my link use my link in the
code dank tastic to get yourself some
bonus goodies it's the same thing for
all of us okay perfect
mine's better though all of Wade's
audience used my link go to my channel
here's my way I'm not falling for that
again use my link my leg thank times
bobs like I'm on bond with Bob on this
way Bob you want a free tea 127 500
golden 7 days a premium you want to use
my link or and think about this Bob's
link yeah my link
Bob's link smells like bacon I like
bacon and the smell of bacon ways link
smells like Limburger spread a doctor
named Limburger and he did a good job of
my spine so I'm fine with that too you
know what way do you really drill down
to what's important yeah good job man
what's important is that you use Bob's
link what's important
yeah he's you know he's right he's my
like I was waiting for you to like
contradict me what's important is that
you were right wow this might be that
Bob first what I've actually got tears
in my eyes I'm not used to you guys
being something sometimes Wade just not
one more recording stuff
I didn't hear a goddamn thing if you
want to get the goodies you have to put
in the code when you make the account
yes that's very important we put that
over screen Dana tank tastic we put mine
is greater myself but me maybe bigger
take a picture of me and take my teeth
and make letters out of my teeth and
make a teeth fun my teeth that gray may
get at you through my teeth right yeah
mines gonna be spelled out in tanks
mines Hanks make spelled out in tank
bullets round all big bullets is
accepted look let's start this okay okay
t 127 crew ain't it to win it
oh hey you're way in the left mark
I'd been all redone right so these are
like bigger fancier maps all right I
like that we're all charging now save
new oh yeah nice nice that's a little
shrunken and little comeback Palooza I
don't think he's gonna fall for it he
might fall for it you never know Oh mark
you know what mark I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] on your flank what are you
doing over here what do you mean I'm not
the best sniper it turns out turns out
not best you're not good though for
whatever that's worth
yeah yeah I am oh boy this is an open
field I'm just gonna kill I just got a
kill and one in friends with one kill on
the board yeah nice and together cuz
we're a team that's a shared kills
anybody winning currently good job
everyone equally good all right I'm
gonna charge up the middle here I don't
have a mark there's a big bad boy
there's a big bad boy you're a big baby
if you think that I'm afraid of this
mark our friend just died right between
us
carefully put another our dead friend
that's awkward there we go
so mark around to our right we can go up
there and it like the castle area see I
see a sweet like flank these fellows
flank these fellows oh jeez UM's they
rimmed me and then straight kamikaze
right yeah two kills bro to kill two
killer not mark my that guy had a
mission out for me oh hey there's only
four friendly tanks alive
i fee I feel like we've may have been
let down here by our allies oh and
they're capturing our base oh wow that's
the three on oh ho do you mind what I
want to stop for to make a shooters oh
boy oh I'm I'm disabled oh hey Bob
that's not a good spot yeah I can't move
oh god I can move again Oh
here yeah man well Wade said you're all
fancy they got camouflage ooh oh wait
wait wait wait wait what you got hit I
got hit from behind though yep
oh no I see their point that's more than
most of our team yeah we gotten all the
way over here well I think we're gonna
win though we did the majority of the
work I didn't get any kills but we
damage the guy pretty good early on you
know that was moderately good I feel
like we're the three best players in the
world we are the feet head I'm ready to
rumble all the points fall like weird
for good good we are so good dreams just
some big old Hills you know what hi RiRi
slats yeah oh this is Scotland okay we
were at Jack's home for a minute this is
definitely bagpipes playing yeah same
thing right hey buds here we go yeah
this map looks a lot more open than the
last one yeah so cover is gonna be a
little bit trickier to state there's
mountains over there yeah you just gotta
you gotta use defilade yeah you're just
totally bailing Wade yeah what wait
driving straight at the mountains climb
up these mountains well you guys are
drive through the field I want to get on
the road if like the road might be a
little fast
right right right of course I want to
see how close they can ride well we
already have an enemy up on this hill Oh
bit the bits yeah he's fine all right
wait I'm coming to bind you I'm charging
up the hill alongside you all right all
right we might as well stick together
right lads
right lads I'm trying to help Stuart
here but Stuart's got a two on one
Stuart's kicking ass jeez
get him Stu all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna pop up right outside this hill
they're never gonna see me coming up
from the ocean I'm on your 3:30 my 4:00
4:15 I'm at a time oh my there's so many
tanks boys - oh man Susan
[Music]
hate to see you die I'm dead now my
goodness there's a sniper way on the
hill out there okay that could have gone
better
oh wait Oh mark like to your right I got
by someone who was speedy they were
speedy speedy who what you got
annihilated nyah lated it's five to five
we're doing all right let's ignore the
fact that Wade and I are dead
everything's going well
yeah okay so six four five all right
right Oh what is happening to you that
happened to me one two seven that was my
brother I don't think that was a 127 I
think we all got killed by t4 tanks old
in 37 is like launching mortars oh maybe
that's what got us man it's still good
turn it was like a pretty decent battle
and yeah our face to being captured okay
sure love the machine gun tank those
actually seem like they're very
effective the machine guns yeah you know
that one that's murder and everybody
yeah that's it was that one was getting
you guys I thought was some kind of
mortar no it was straight fire from
somebody just boss is there a way to do
a battle with people who are bad at this
game you guys want to do it the sneaky
tactical round you want to just chill
chill in the back and see wait and see
and not die right away maybe like snipe
and we could snipe we can yeah we've got
tiny little piddly cannons but that we
can just well I mean not all of us is
tiny little piddly cannons it was at the
Eiffel Tower are we in Paris no no that
common misconception it's actually the
Franklin Tower it's home aha Nebraska
for a moment you know I always like
ELISA I mean tell me I think we should
go left into the urban area left and get
the rice out of your ears and and just
like look down these long things but
don't don't stick your little nose out
too far till your shirts it's not safe
how do you know that's okay on the
mini-map at the bottom right they're
starting to spot people well I do want
to give you guys some tank some tank
tips yeah tank do you want a peek
corners so you're gonna shoot you want
to like boom and then back up is a good
force all three to be side by side
absolutely that we can machine got it
well going over all shoot the new shoot
then mark and it's just like boom I'm
gonna take a potshot at whoever Lux is
over here wait nevermind he's gone looks
this dead no looks is not dead he's not
dead looks got it's just no longer
coming our in our alley
not our alley oh that is a big tank her
splosions is that good
always armor not pennant that is a high
tier tank we're shooting at right now
where's that coming from
oh my god oh my god we're all right
we're actually winning this right now so
let's retreat and help our allies over
here I'm actually gonna push this corner
there's no exactly where the two guys
were that we couldn't damage before yes
maybe yeah I'm not asking to change your
mind just to constraint to change help
Matilda out up there Matilda's chasing
down some someone up there you're kind
of in the open air yes I was Hertzog
we got them they're gone we we got him I
don't think I dealt any damage but I
definitely shot out a bit scared of a
little bit there sir literally is one
health right wait
we're there's only three of us left
three of them alive we need to defend
our base wait one of them was diving our
base I think yeah yeah I'm gonna circle
back to
our base and just play D there's a tee
116 pushing right here yeah way do you
see him oh oh yeah you're in the open
move move move I said good on it go
around the other way he's got a he's got
to come to you oh he is coming he's
coming
wait he's coming get ready to shoot him
with me yep penetrate it hurt him it
hurt him it hurt him Karuma
ah wait what happened to the help him I
was trying to back up to get in the
range shoot him wait he's coming wait oh
good shot could track a shot nice miss
nice miss nice nice he's like one shot
as long as he doesn't oh I contributed
there's one of them alive where is he
one two six I don't know he might be all
the way back at their base Wade gopher
the basic order there was one guy way
north I'm not sure if he died or not no
worries
mark said to go for base capture that's
where I'm going you always trust me man
wait if all of you are at their base you
can capture it faster than he can
capture your base yeah but on their bit
our base right now and starts capturing
before they're on it I don't know how
the time difference works
I think it's Mathilda's already over
Matilda died no I'm until didn't die no
it's fine
so it's fine yeah he's north of their
base yeah
wait you have an angle on him he's like
straight down you're you're no it's over
they're gone it's all go we win yeah
don't betray me at the end I don't know
what killed me like someone had a line
on me like one shot it was like it was
just boom boom boom someone was just
laying into me and I couldn't get away I
don't know what I work in from mission
completed
okay mission related victory what it is
sweet and you at home too can get
victory if you use the link in the
description and use the code Bob tactic
my link my link demonically bobsleighing
what about mine if you guys look at all
three videos and you compare links you
will see that bob has the superior link
clearly better
obvious pain bother recommend I've
tasted luxury Bob's flavor is just a
little bit richer I will allow people to
go check but they will see once they're
done that mine is the better link
disagree this draw a strong strong
disagree there
what's the pros about the T 127 it seems
like it's a little bit slower to some
other tanks but maybe a little bit
bulkier than some other tier threes okay
we're meant to where I think we're meant
to be a light mobile tank we're meant to
scout and dip dive and dodge we're not
really big hefty tanks there were some
big hefty tax I think that's also why we
keep getting one shot yeah your your
armor is mostly in your front and your
back is like your weak spot I think all
of us when we've got one shot have
basically someone has found our backside
and we just die in like two seconds if
anyone shoots it's our pad or at our
rear armor yeah because it's basically
like a little sheet of aluminum foil
covering up the hole we climb in
they really gotta fix that I would put
more armor back there because I like to
run away what if we put like some
pillows or something back there just to
kind of comfy yeah what if I put some
dirt so that people can bury me when I
die what are they gonna bury you with
their hands come on can I have your
extra pillows they're gonna bust out
their big meat scoops a half an inch of
dirt I don't think so
Wade ready up god damn it Wade am I in
the party yeah you guys want to do a
little expedition to like the northwest
corner of the map yeah right hooker
right and go hide around some mountains
and try not to die he'll shoot straight
and then right yeah
Yeah right right and then right across
right I'm going on the lake everyone get
on the ice and jump I'm gonna swim
thanks even why our shirts fine this
can't be that deep of water look that we
are the deep water
okay so fast I guess we're more of a
meat all right I'm slamming all right
let's do this I'm gonna right yeah get
that right yeah I'm gonna go round the
mouth of the demon yeah me too give me
in that demon oh I want to get behind
this rock and not come out driving guys
the bt7 watch out for it what what's
going on here
oh there's tanks over here coming in 46
get the t40 swimming in coming in hot
and heavy
Boosh got him hit him get him boys
always so low finish them off God
another oh yeah to the M team I see him
I hit him he's a thick boy maybe hurt
him all right just like bobbing back and
forth the cover oh god he's got more
friends that you eat 57 we're on our way
we're basically there miss yeah we're
totally we got mark you got to stop
going so fast man you're gonna help me
get up
oh he's dead all right we're here who
just did that
where's all the bad guys they're at
their bow who's hitting me from the left
from the left on the hill I'm dead oh
I'm gonna need lots of go
oh um Oh what the hell he was so fast
and Hardy did you see how fast in
advantaging he turned on his nos he just
really wanted that yeah we are without
dead oh yeah alright hell did that guy
come from kill on one somebody I did it
was like Rambo yeah you'd work yeah you
were like Rambo
you died 27 here come on oh yeah get
long go oh yeah that's a meaty hit oh oh
nice
that looks like a very tanky tank well
men shooting from like on huh I see
shells coming in from like 45-degree
angles up in the sky locusts you look at
fly he's just like a artillery thing in
the back yeah oh yeah I guess he is oh
god he's got a mortar he doesn't have it
oh yeah yeah he's just like a big gun
not even a full tank just like a half
armored thing sitting way in the back
it's 5 to 3 this smell nice unless some
crazy person just Rambo's them like
marketed and that's definitely a good
thing to do I feel like that was a
compliment but it it was a compliment
Scruffy's got four kills yeah well thank
God he's on our side
hey halsy zone the other team oh man I
love your music oh and there's boomer Oh
boomer boomer hey look this Scruffy's
driving past where we all died yeah oh
yeah that team but he's not screaming
like we were I don't think he's doing it
right do it to him scruff get him screw
oh actually I don't know if birch gun is
aware that he is Oh
he disappeared it's so hard that he
ain't even here
oh oh oh no buy shots
we're lied to two down two down
Scruffy's being real hesitant here I
feel like his brows is rougher he's
playing the full reach-around strat
right now I feel like now's the time to
really get in there get know I felt like
the first second of the match was the
times we had an exhilarating experience
it was awesome
what a shot scruff whoa how did you get
back in there Rafi has six kills now
gruff ease gun is like way bigger than
mine I'm just comparing it's so much
bigger than mine it's larger than
anything ever I feel like our tanks are
for something that we are unaware of I
think what they're mostly for is not
don't not what you're doing don't do
that why not it worked that got a kill I
mean it is hard to argue with that
that's true all right mark knows please
do it now this one just appears to be a
big field I don't like this we could
help we get you to this I got you I'm
gonna follow you guys it is just one
field middle and just see what develops
yeah let's get behind a bush
there's a nice little defilade here like
south of us like over where over where
I'm heading
yep and up but apparently everyone else
on our team just sort of hide behind
this and like just like exists for a
while someone's gonna notice that tree
missing but it's so fine right now all
right they seem to be pushing the north
interview off and just watch this North
angle from here alright well I'm gonna
stay right here I like my bush I like my
boy
I like your Bush that's cool child squad
first blissed off second blood looks
like that strap too gonna be an easy one
I think bought it hey oh yeah Oh doing
damage that dude is so wrecked right now
that guy's dunzo
none of us got that kill all right
several damage to that one all right I'm
scoping out the area but m2 is just like
I'm going much bunch more in that town
north east oh yeah I see there's a big
hole D w201 spotted Lago Lago where
uh-huh oh yeah yes still in the town I
don't think I got a shot on that so I'm
gonna shoot over here
yep I see Lago gonna get a shot on him
oh yeah yeah miss got a couple hits
ricocheting
oh wow oh my god oh whoa whoa whoa where
artillery guy I don't know what angle
but yeah we're getting a little circled
and scooched ooh
we are really ouchies ooh Bob I'm not
feeling so good I don't feel so good mr.
Bob I hate to tell you this but it's
3:00 to 7:00 right now
get him charging you got em - coming up
the middle oh no Marquis proud oh god
I'm dead go for the weak oh they all
waited for em to to really come in there
make a distraction gun it's just got
this it's a substantial amount of ouch
it to pie they're taking our base well
you just run through the houses I didn't
try that never crossed my mind if he did
though I got six kills I was well he
should have been on a better team that's
more than three of us combined a three
of us at least we equal three yeah yeah
well this has been fun
remember there's a beautiful shiny
bright link if you want to play this for
yourself right there my description
Bob's description my description I like
yeah I mean I've got one in mine too and
it's very nice and shiny but like Bob's
is just a little bit shinier and marks
exists I think is it well I mean it
doesn't just exist it thrives
it doesn't feel a need to justify its
existence it's doing pretty well for
itself and don't worry I'm going to
justify it's a super for it
succeeding but are your legs tank tastic
yeah probably yes sir
okay are yours is yours is our your your
link fantastic
[Music]
you